brian is with us in kansas city hey
brian
welcome to the ramsay show hi dave thank
you
um so my question today is uh
basically me and my wife decided that
this was going to be the best year to
build a house and we're kind of finding
out
that's not really true so
we went under contract two months ago
gave our contractor the earnest money
and the deposit
haven't really heard a lot back from our
contractor
um they haven't broken ground yet
and then last week we got an email that
said
due to material prices increasing they
have to raise the price of us
of the materials and they have to raise
the price of the house
so um basically i kind of pushed back on
that went back and forth with them for a
little bit
and they said in the contract that
there's
paragraph 30 they have the right to
raise the price based on material
um so to look to my mortgage guy
and he had his legal team look at it
and it looks like the only out that we
have
is if the loan gets denied they
illegally have to give us our money back
um what do you think about the morality
of that
does that seem like a moral choice
that's good
does it not um just your thoughts that
you
that you walk away from the deal yes sir
okay uh not the morality of them raising
prices
no not the morality of the morality of
me walking away from a contract that i
agreed to
yeah that was dumb uh so what is the
how much did they raise the prices
uh 3.5 percent so it was about 10
dollars uh and the other thing in the
email they said is that they can no
longer lock down prices with their
vendors
so whenever they order say
lumber for frame of the house whatever
the price of lumber is that day is
what we'll have to pay so it looks like
the price of the house is going to
increase also
more than what they've already told you
yes sir
okay and what's the price range of the
home what is the price overall
uh the price was 314
and it's about 325 now okay
and what's your household income
about 90 000 okay
well
um to start with let's just say that
what they're telling you is the truth
lumber is going up rapidly that's not a
lie
um and i and they have the
contractual ability to raise the price
and my guess is the market's hot enough
that if you don't buy the house they can
sell it somebody else
i would agree yeah so i i don't think
they're going to be harmed
in this situation um
but basically you'd have to get a turn
down letter uh turning you down
for the loan from your mortgage broker
yeah he said that's no problem okay
all right um
i don't have an issue with the morality
i mean the deal has changed
uh nobody in this deal anticipated that
the deal was going to change
uh and based on the change you don't
want to be in the deal
you know i don't want to be in a house
that i feel like
i kind of got you know the
bad end of the stick i don't i don't
think you're getting the batting of the
stick i think i think if you're
if you were building a cost plus house
which is how i build mine
meaning i buy i pay the costs and i pay
the builder a flat fee to manage the
project
you would be absorbing all of the
increases
i'm building a commercial building that
we break ground on a conference center
here
and our steel prices doubled and we
hadn't even broke ground yet
and i'm that's all on me because the
contractor just
manages the project in a commercial
project they don't
they don't it's not it's not a turnkey
deal they pay they pay them a contractor
fee
and we pay the materials and so
um and and steel doubled
and uh so i've just got to go well do i
really want to do this well yeah i'm
gonna do it but i
told him go and buy the steel and put it
out there in the field somewhere so it
doesn't double again in the next 18
months while we're screwing around with
this thing but
um but that's the reality steel plywood
lumber packages glue
wire there's a shortage of everything
because all the factories shut down
during covet and the shortage has driven
the
price up uh and then add to that that
the real estate market got white hot
coming out of covet in most areas so
i don't i don't think you're being
hoodooed i don't think they're messing
you over
if i did i just pull a plug on heartbeat
just on principle but
uh the other thing is this um you know
at
10 years from today uh
is this all you're still gonna be
thinking about if you're living in this
house
i feel like probably yeah yeah it's
going to eat at you for the yeah you
need to get out of the deal then
because it's just going to eat at you
okay but i don't think this guy's i
don't think this guy's a crook
okay yeah you know i didn't get that
vibe from them either it's just
they're asking us to take their word
like hey
you know we're telling you we don't know
what the prices are going to be
but please take our word that we're
going to try not to raise the prices and
yeah he's not trying though that didn't
work last time yeah but i mean
but but the difference is unmet
expectations you guys entered into this
nobody saw this lumber shortage coming
and so i mean he's probably built houses
10 years and never faced this one time
and all of a sudden the stinking lumber
package went up
you know a ton and that's the major
component in a residential home is the
lumber package is your biggest item on
your line items
and so you know he's he he's like crap
now i gotta go do
now i gotta go deal with a customer
who's gonna be mad like i did something
wrong and i didn't do anything wrong i
just got screwed myself by the situation
so
um i i don't think the guy's a bad guy
um he is passing the cost on to you
which he contractually
nobody ever thought you'd ever activate
that little known clause of the contract
but he's
able to do that and uh so but i think
the biggest thing is
you're just not ever going to be happy
here so you're better off to be done
and um you know you can sit down with
them
and tell them that and so you can either
let me go or i'll you know i'll get a
letter
uh on the turn down and then i'll be let
go so
um he probably doesn't want to build a
house for you if you're unhappy the
whole time anyway
especially given that he probably has a
line around the block of people wanting
to buy the house without you
so and they'll pay whatever the prices
are
in most cases i don't know but i would
suspect kansas city is like a lot of
these other places right now